[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y france 24
hoy dedicado al fútbol femenino es
posible su profesionalización con qué
barreras se están encontrando las
mujeres para vivir del fútbol podrán
algún día cobrar los mismos salarios que
los hombres muchas cuestiones en torno
al fútbol femenino que cada vez tiene
más adeptos y nadie mejor para hablarnos
de todo esto que victor obinna
muchísimas gracias víctor por estar con
nosotros bueno usted nació en boston
eeuu pero se crió en varias ciudades en
11 ciudades me decía antes
también vivió en argentina fue en ese
país donde se enamoró del fútbol forofa
del racing de avellaneda ha sido agente
de futbolistas hombres con una agencia
que fundó en miami con su madre la
primera dirigida exclusivamente por
mujeres y también ha creado la
aplicación gloria que conecta a la
comunidad mundial del fútbol y además es
embajadora de la onu mujeres por la
igualdad de género en el fútbol este
lunes asistió a la del 'balón de oro' el
séptimo para el argentino lionel messi y
el primero para la española alexia
putellas que en su discurso
reivindicaba el fútbol femenino y además
pedía su profesionalización no cuál es
el diagnóstico que usted hace del fútbol
femenino bueno primero que nada muchas
gracias por recibirme y bueno este es un
tema obviamente que a mí me apasiona
mucho creo que el fútbol femenino viene
a interrumpir una industria que hace 100
años funciona de la misma manera por
ende se convierte en algo muy
emocionante para cualquier persona que
ama este deporte es un emprendimiento
dentro de una institución y creo que hoy
en día las marcas las jugadoras los
clubes y hasta los profesionales en
tecnología nos estamos todos acomodando
a este caballo de troya que es lo que va
a explotar lo que empieza como valor
eterno
en qué país eso está avanzando más en la
profesionalización del fútbol femenino
bueno a ver eeuu siempre fue el país
número uno
en el fútbol es un deporte para mujeres
no es un deporte para hombres que creo
que ese es como radicalmente diferente
del resto del mundo pero hoy en día en
europa estamos viendo un avance
gigantesco
lo que están haciendo las ligas y los
clubes dentro de europa es es alucinante
y también de vuelta muy emocionante
hablábamos justamente desde eeuu donde
tal vez haya más facilidades para para
las mujeres el fútbol femenino es mucho
más importante que el fútbol masculino
en ese país que se puede aprender del
fútbol femenino estadounidense que se
está haciendo bien allí y que se está
haciendo mal bueno a ver el atletismo
creo que es la parte que mejor han hecho
los americanos hasta ahora los jugadores
están entregada desde muy temprano a los
cinco o seis años cuando deciden jugar
al fútbol porque es muy normal
empiezan a entrenarse de buena manera
que en el resto del mundo eso todavía no
está pasando obviamente con la inversión
que hubo desde el mundial-2010 y no de
acá en francia
cambiando las cosas creo que por ese
lado obviamente estamos viendo en
jugadores que pueden jugar 90 minutos y
lo pueden hacer con mucha calidad y por
ende cuando vemos al equipo nacional de
eeuu jugar contra cualquier otro equipo
del mundo casi siempre llevan ventaja
eso es la buena parte ahora del lado del
lado malo o no o no tan buena creo que
eeuu tiene mucho para aprender de las
franquicias son marcas más establecidas
acá en europa que estamos viendo equipos
como el barcelona al real madrid el
bayern munich el país sánchez más que
tiene obviamente muchos muchos años en
el fútbol desarrollar sus marcas para
mujeres que obviamente son reconocidas
ya por todo el mundo que en eeuu no está
pasando las marcas de la agenda burgués
el son son marcas equipos que se han
creado hace cinco seis siete años son
muy nuevas y la gente no las reconoce
todos
ahora voy a hacer una comparación
virtual que no sé si
la puedo hacer pero la vamos a hacer
igual no el según la revista forbes los
jugadores mejor pagados en 2021 son el
portugués cristiano ronaldo con 125
millones de dólares salario más más
bonificaciones y el argentino lionel
messi con 110 millones de dólares en el
caso de las chicas el club que mejor
paga es el francés olympique de lyon que
además ha tenido muchos éxitos
por ejemplo en ese club amandi y cobra
casi 400 mil dólares anuales o sea
estamos dando de 125 millones de dólares
anuales y 400 mil dólares anuales
veremos algún día aumentar los salarios
de las jugadoras chicas bueno si
consideramos que hace dos años los
salarios más altos serán de 100.000 y
eso era una locura creo que estamos
viendo obviamente un claro crecimiento
de ese lado y yo estoy muy convencida de
que en los próximos 10-15 vamos a ver un
crecimiento gigantesco y una igualdad en
el tema de los salarios porque
justamente las mujeres se van a
convertir en atletas seguidas por muchas
otras mujeres también y una nueva
audiencia se va a introducir a este
deporte que siempre fue reservado para
los hombres
pero bueno yo de vuelta hay mucho mucho
trabajo por hacer adelante y si pensamos
que en el 2017 neymar también que juega
en parís está ganando lo mismo que las
las mejores 1500 jugadoras del mundo
combinadas así que hay lugar para
crecimiento seguro en américa latina
donde el fútbol es el deporte rey no en
casi todos los países cuál es la
situación de las mujeres futbolistas
está creciendo y creo que hace bastante
es el mundial bueno en un lugar como
argentina de las mujeres futbolistas no
es tan profesionalizadas hoy en día lo
están
y obviamente eso está haciendo que el
deporte crezca a pasos agigantados a
temprana edad no yo por ejemplo nunca
jugué al fútbol pero soy fanática y eso
era porque mis padres nunca habían
pensado que eso era una opción para mí y
creo que eso está cambiando mucho y
bueno vamos a ver dónde va pero se están
mejorando la calidad de
la técnica del fútbol están en el adn de
las jugadoras latinoamericanas que
justamente seguimos hablando de
latinoamérica y de un aspecto del fútbol
el fútbol puede empoderar y ya tiene un
proyecto en brasil en las favelas muy
interesantes con unos mujeres cuéntenos
ahora el fútbol puede generar igualdad
de género yo soy muy creyente de eso
creo que cuando uno ve historias de
mujeres que han logrado cosas en el
fútbol es una evidencia de la igualdad
de género justamente porque este deporte
siempre fue para hombres
en brásil arrancamos con un documental
que cuenta las historias de 10 mujeres
en 10 países diferentes que logran
igualdad de género a través del fútbol
usando el fútbol como vehículo para
lograr esa igualdad arrancamos en brasil
con la historia de una chica que decía
jugar al fútbol a una temprana edad y el
padre no la deja por ende la madre
decide juntar la plata y hacerlo igual y
hoy en día busca ser profesional en un
país en donde hace
no más de dos años no era no era un
deporte profesional
quería que comentáramos también el tema
de los abusos sexuales en el fútbol
porque habido denuncias en eeuu colombia
afganistán uno de los últimos casos ha
sido venezuela donde 24 jugadoras de
distintos equipos de la selección
denuncian que sufrieron abusos por parte
del ex entrenador panameño que se
merezca no sé si lo digo bien es algo
generalizado esto desgraciadamente sí
creo que lo vemos en todas las
industrias el fútbol será una de las
últimas que sale a tener un movimiento
era un mito
desgraciadamente es parte de la cultura
parte de que hasta ahora mucha gente no
le prestaba atención entonces pasaba lo
que tenía que pasar
pero bueno de vuelta creo que los
jugadores están teniendo mucho más
apoyo cuando salen a reivindicarse
y obviamente en la inicial que es la
liga más allá del mundo que marca el
paso del resto del mundo en lo que es
fútbol femenino ha tenido hace muy poco
también en la misma ocasión un
movimiento mitú que generó que su
comisionado con la presidenta de la liga
tuviera que irse porque no no hizo las
cosas muy bien
hay países donde ser futbolista tiene
además más dificultades añadidas estoy
pensado en afganistán con la vuelta de
los talibanes usted consiguió con otra
futbolista con una futbolista de origen
afgano en eeuu poder sacar a deportistas
como como fue bueno nadie a nadie me
juego en el park distance drama así que
también de acá
si fue durante un torneo femenino
amistoso en donde el transition remind
bayern múnich fueron a jugar contra dos
equipos en eeuu y rompió todo lo que
estaba pasando en afganistán y juntas
decidimos armar un fan racing para poder
mandar apoyo económico a las mujeres que
estaban padeciendo un momento en la
historia que ninguna mujer hubiese
querido ver hoy en día
y bueno juntamos más de 100 mil dólares
en muy pocos días
y esto puede ayudar a que muchas mujeres
se vayan de un país en donde no las
respetan lo decíamos al principio se
creó la aplicación gloria que permite
conectar a los aficionados del fútbol de
todo el mundo no como crear una
comunidad universal de los forofos del
fútbol dedica un amplio espacio al
fútbol femenino pero no es exclusivo del
fútbol femenino explíquenos cómo cómo
funciona cómo está creando esta
comunidad universal del fútbol glòria
busca hacer la casa del fútbol online es
un lugar en donde uno puede seguir
experimentando el fútbol una vez que se
hayan terminado los partidos una vez que
se haya ido del estadio una vez que
hayan terminado a jugar al fútbol con
socios y es una comunidad para todos
entonces obviamente eso incluye el
fútbol femenino pero nosotros no hacemos
la distinción o la segregación yo no
creo en eso particularmente
habiendo sido fanática toda mi vida para
un deporte que no era un deporte para
meego creado para mí hoy en día busco
con mi equipo generar un producto
deje e incluya a cualquier persona que
quiera participar de este deporte a
través de comunidades cualquier persona
dentro de gloria dentro de la aplicación
puede crear una comunidad alrededor de
cualquier tema dentro del fútbol sean
fanáticos de messis fanáticos el país
alemán que hoy en día también de alguna
manera coincidentemente es nuestra
comunidad más grande y más potente
y dentro de ese contexto puedan
comunicarse con otra gente alrededor del
mundo
la aplicación hoy en día está en beta
con invitación privada pero sea ha sido
baja en más de 109 países que para mí es
una locura más de la mitad del mundo
tienen la aplicación teléfono que
muestra también el peeling global que
tiene este deporte bueno pues le
deseamos muchísimo éxito con gloria y
que cada vez haya más fútbol femenino en
el mundo en el mundo muchísimas gracias
victor obinna por haber estado con
nosotros muchas gracias a ustedes y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también por internet en rf
y mundo.com y en france24 punto com
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]